هذا بالفعل عام من أكبر أزمة إنسانية لم يسبق لها مثيل
منذ
الحرب العالمية
الثانية ، حيث تتزايد التحديات التي نواجهها
، ونحن نواجه الآن أزمة غذائية.
ممرات
رجال الشرطة منذ عام 2015 لرفع مستوى الوعي حول كيفية
اعتبار النظم الغذائية جزءًا مهمًا من
النقاش المناخي ، فإن
مؤسس مؤسسة Think Tank لديه آمال كبيرة في حدث هذا العام
الذي سيعقد في
منتجع البحر الأحمر المصري بمدينة شارما ،
الإصدارات السابقة من رجال الشرطة  وأنا
أذهب إليهم منذ الشرطي 21 ، وهناك عدد
من الأجنحة التي تلفت الانتباه إلى
قضايا مختلفة ولكن لم يكن
هناك أبدًا جناحًا خاصًا بالطعام.
نحن نطوره إلى كيفية
نقله إلى التخلص منه
وكل أجزاء هذا النظام
تلحق خسائر فادحة بالبيئة
إذا نظرت إلى الطعام كنظام
تبحث عنه  أكثر من ثلث
انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري العالمية ، ولكن إذا
استدرت نظام إنتاج الغذاء
هذا ، فيمكن أن يساعد في الواقع في مواجهة
أزمة المناخ ، وهذا هو
الهدف النهائي لأكثر من 15 منظمة عالمية من
المقرر أن تشارك في
جناح أنظمة الغذاء بما يتجاوز
المحادثة المعتادة وإظهار كيفية
قيامهم بتنفيذ طرق أنظف صديقة للبيئة
لإنتاج الطعام ، لا يمكننا الاعتماد
فقط على مسار المفاوضات
لأن ذلك يستغرق وقتًا ، لذا لا
يتعلق الأمر بالمناقشة ، إنه في الحقيقة حول
الحلول
من الزراعة العمودية إلى اللحوم المزروعة
وعدد كبير من الاستدامة  والحلول الذكية
سيتم عرضها
، أعتقد أننا نفهم الآن فقط مدى
إمكانات الابتكار
والأعمال الموجودة في تحويل نظامنا الغذائي
إلى شيء أكثر
استدامة وأكثر تنوعًا وأكثر
ذكاءً
بصرف النظر عن الفوائد البيئية للتحول إلى البيئة
لإعادة تشكيل الطعام
يمكن للنظام أن يخلق بونًا اقتصاديًا يقول أحد
التقديرات إنه يمكن أن يولده  أكلوا أكثر
من 4.5 تريليون دولار سنويًا بحلول عام 2030 ،
وهو رقم واعد لم يتحقق إلا
بصوت جماعي في 27 CNN
الأجنبية
[موسيقى] هذا العام